(gentle music)
- Welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich.
And as you know, on my channel,
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
And this is why I'm especially happy
that today's video is
sponsored by INVERTO.
INVERTO is a consulting company
that focuses on supply chain management
and procurement consulting.
They're part of the
Boston Consulting Group.
And here today, I'm standing in front
of their Munich offices
and we are meeting Lars.
Lars is a Managing Director,
a partner of INVERTO here in Munich.
And Lars is going to show
us how the typical day
of the life of a consultant,
of a partner here in Munich looks like.
So let's get into it.
- Hey, everybody.
My name is Lars.
I'm Managing Director at INVERTO.
And as you can see,
with such nice weather,
I love to ride my bike to
the office in the morning.
I had to drop off my daughter
in the kindergarten a minute ago.
And I'm happy to take you on a little tour
on my regular day with INVERTO today.
And yeah, I would say let's get started.
(gentle music)
- So we just came together here
to do a couple of health tests.
So of course, at INVERTO at the moment,
there's home office policy.
There is some flexibility
following a hygiene concept
to come to the office
on a very limited basis.
Today, of course, a little
bit more people came
just for the video.
Again, we are tested,
I am also vaccinated.
So trust this is going to be safe.
Let's do it.
(gentle music)
- Hey, Marie.
Morning.
- Hi.
- Okay, I'm done with my meeting.
If you want, we can quickly sit together
about your first month at INVERTO.
- Yeah.
- Hey, Marie.
You're now one month with
us in the Munich team.
And yeah, obviously, I'm curious to know
if you got to know our people already,
how was the onboarding?
- Yeah, of course it's quite difficult
to start in these times.
But I got the chance already
to get to know a few people
and all are trying their best
to feel very welcome here.
And we already had some lunch dates.
We have had quite a few formats
to get to know each other
like the online lunch dates
and also the beer fridge.
So yep, it's cool.
- So now we need to give Lars some privacy
for some confidential calls.
We're going to catch up with
him in a couple of hours.
And in the meantime,
I have the opportunity
to talk to some other colleagues of Lars.
So let's get in here, do
some little interviews,
and hope that this is
going to be interesting
for all of you.
- We're focusing on
procurement and logistics.
Within procurement, for example,
there are different types
of topics we can support.
It's about organizational topics
but it's also about realizing savings
and making some impact at the client.
So usually, actually we start
with an opportunity assessment phase
which takes like four to six weeks,
where we elaborate all the potentials,
all the synergies within that company.
And the outcome is more or less
a PowerPoint slide deck, usually.
However, then actually
we start then execution
and that makes us probably very different
to other consultancies.
So we define initiatives on
the very operational level
and then we execute them
and bring them into reality.
And that actually means like
we negotiate with suppliers,
we identify the tactics individually
for each of these type of negotiations
together with the client.
We do the negotiations and
then we come to a conclusion
together with their team.
And then we have actually
immediately the impact
for the client.
- And this is also, because I also did
a couple of procurement projects
in my time in consulting,
and this is really what I
liked most about this topic.
Contrary to many other types of projects,
while you are there, you're
really seeing the impact
and you are driving the impact.
This is really what's special about it.
So yes, great opportunity.
- So we just picked up Lars from his office.
I think you are done now with your calls.
And now we have some time to go to lunch.
So we pre-ordered a couple of bagels,
so I'm very hungry.
So I'm looking forward to that.
So let's follow us and let's go.
So Lars, now you had a couple of calls.
We are, of course, quite excited to learn
and understand what these were all about.
Can you maybe just share the
topics of what you discussed?
- Yeah, sure.
So now in the current situation we have
with all the remote work,
the number and frequency of
calls is like really incredible.
Like a lot of like half hour check-ins,
one hour meetings with the teams,
and that's also what I did this morning.
So it was for two of my teams
for two different projects.
We did a check-in, let's say, for the week
to understand what's going on,
what our priority is,
what meetings come up
with higher management with our client.
And yeah, who's doing
what and on what topics?
And then I had a longer
review with one of my teams
where we went through all the topics.
So all the consultants basically presented
where they are standing,
what are current challenges?
And that was one topic.
In between, a potential client called,
where we send out late on Friday an offer,
to give us some feedback.
Yeah, I think that was about it.
And you were taking part
also in this meeting
with Marie in the office,
who is one month with us.
So I wanted to know from
her how the onboarding was,
how she's doing,
how she was, let's say,
also welcomed by the team.
Yeah, I think that was it
in the last 2 1/2 hours.
- Makes sense.
And this really sounds like
we earned our lunch very much,
so very much looking
forward to that, Lars.
- Yeah, me too.
(upbeat music)
- So now we are here in Munich, actually,
in the English Garden
and enjoying our lunch.
But now please be also honest,
is this the case every single time?
Do you always have the opportunity
to have lunch like this?
- So obviously, we try to
have some break every day.
Sometimes it's in front of the computer.
Sometimes we do manage
to go with a bigger group
to a restaurant and enjoy
an hour of lunch break.
Or to go here to the English Gardens,
but it's not working everyday.
Like me personally,
I do need to have food sometime in between
or I run out of energy.
But yeah, it's not always in
such a nice scenery, yeah.
- It would have surprised
me if he would have said
anything else.
- Yeah, it's true.
- So we're have back here from lunch.
Like I said, this is the Lars' office.
And indeed now I know that
you have several calls
lined up for this afternoon.
I think the one very important one.
Maybe you can tell us more about this.
- Yeah, most important one right now
is a steering committee meeting
for a full potential plan
we're doing for an engineering company
and started to work
for them two weeks ago.
- So what is a steerco, Lars?
Because I know that steercos
are very important meetings,
also frequently had them.
Can you maybe just fill us a little bit,
what's this all about?
- Yeah, it's indeed quite important.
This is also why we need to do
it in the middle of the day.
Because from the top
management of our client,
people from Asia Pacific,
Europe, and Americas will join.
So we need to look at the time zones.
So steering committee meeting
is really about showing
what findings we have
from the couple of first
weeks with our client
and also making important
decisions for the way forward,
so the next weeks to follow.
- So what is this like?
Can you just talk about the expectations,
the pressures that you're facing?
- Yeah, actually, thanks
for mentioning that.
But on us as the procurement work stream
all of this cool thing,
where our colleagues from BCG
are also doing strategy,
production footprint,
sales activities, and so on.
I would say right now there's
quite a little bit of pressure
on the Inverto team because procurement
is always the first workstream to deliver
P&L savings to our clients.
So all eyes on us today.
So fingers crossed that
they like what we found
and that they agree to our conclusions.
- So looking a bit forward
to the feedback afterwards.
Happy we're gonna talk about this.
- If you are looking for
new job opportunity,
INVERTO is hiring a significant
number of consultants this year.
So in the video description,
I will insert a link
to a career event, coffee and career talk,
where INVERTO is answering
all your questions
about what it's like to work at INVERTO,
to work as a consultant.
This event will take place in German.
So if you are an international applicant,
they still have lots of other vacancies
in many of their European offices.
I will link this career
page there as well.
So have a look, browse around.
And I trust if you're interested
in a career in consulting,
this might be something relevant to you.
- So welcome back and let's see
whether Lars is now done with the steerco
and what he has to say.
So Lars, steerco is over?
- Yes, yes, it's over.
It took a few extra minutes
but now we are done.
- Awesome, how was it?
- It was good.
So we knew it's a challenging audience.
And we got some challenging questions,
but as a team, yeah, I
think we were very good
in answering them.
And also from our side, placed
some critical statements
toward the client,
where we need to improve
or they need to improve
on the way forward.
And they agreed with our perspective.
So yeah, we agreed on next steps
following the coming weeks.
A lot of workshops ongoing.
We now need to prepare
to deliver all this.
And yeah, it's another four weeks now
to the next, the final steerco already
in this first phase of the project.
And yeah, we know what to
do, how to do it, all good.
- It sounds like a good outcome.
So if it's okay for you, can I ask you
a couple of more questions on
what is like to be a partner
at a consulting firm?
- Yeah, sure.
- So I guess let's go over-
- Yes.
- Thank you.
So Lars, thanks for taking the time
to sit with me here today and talk a bit
about what it's like to be a consultant,
and specifically, to be a partner.
Now, before we jump into this later aspect
of it, of being a partner,
I know that many people in my audience
here at Firm Learning
are really interested
to become a consultant as well.
And I trust that many of
you are asking yourselves,
well, how do I know whether
this career as a consultant
is right for me, whether
I will have the potential
to become a good consultant?
How would you reply to that?
- Yeah, and not such an easy question.
And actually, we are asking
us the question ourselves
when we're doing recruiting interviews,
what are the most important traits
somebody needs to bring?
And obviously, you need to be,
let's say, quick and sharp,
and need to have a good understanding.
And the willingness to learn,
I think, is one very important aspect.
Because we know that
people from university
or also coming from other jobs,
they don't know everything
they will need as a consultant.
- This very much resonates
with my own experience
in consulting for sure.
And this is maybe then a great transition
to the next thing that
I hope also many of you
will be interested in.
And this is, now, let's imagine
you work as a consultant.
You already made it, or
may be also in another role
in industry, another high-paced career.
And now of course, you
don't just wanna make
a solid a good job, but you
really wanna make a great job.
Do you wanna be successful?
You really wanna do your best.
So from your perspective,
what distinguishes a good consultant
from a great consultant?
How are you really outstanding?
What do you need to do?
What distinguishes these
two types of provides?
- Yeah, so that's a question I often get
as a coach for our people internally,
where I take, let's say,
a career advisor role
throughout a couple of years
for younger colleagues.
And for me, one of the
most important topics here
would be to be proactive.
So not reacting on what
your project manager,
the client demands or whatever,
but always trying to think
one or two steps ahead,
what's happening next?
What do I need to prepare now
to make the project successful
in the next step?
And then secondly, also, an
advice I give very many people
within our organization, is
also to think in solutions.
So not come back in your project team,
to your project manager, or
whatever, with a problem.
It's great to ask questions.
If you have a problem,
you should come back.
But when you come back, I
expect the very good people
always to have thought
through a different series,
let's say, of solutions they might have.
And they can still ask
me, "Is it the right one?"
Maybe I have a totally different one.
But if I see they thought
about it, they have
some good first ideas,
then it's much more easier.
And this is also making the difference
to find the right solution.
And not just here's my
problem, solve it for me.
- So I'm with Marie today.
Marie started at Inverto a month ago.
And I'm looking forward to see
a little bit of the office.
Marie, can you show us around?
- Yeah, sure, I can show you the office.
- So let's do it.
- So here's our kitchen where
you can meet the colleagues
and have some lunch time.
And here you can see all
of the team in Munich.
And of course during the current situation,
we cannot meet everyone here.
But yeah, we have also
coffee to get new energy
for a working day.
So let's see the rest of the office.
And this is, for example,
one of our offices.
We have a flexibility,
yeah, situation that
you can book your room
if you are in the office.
And of course, there are
just a quite few people.
- So now it's already quite
late in the afternoon, Lars,
but we had the opportunity
to follow you around
for quite some time.
You need to be honest with us,
how representative was this day really?
Is this really how it goes every day?
How does it usually really look like?
- So obviously, every day
can be very different.
But I think for the current situation
with the travel restrictions still on,
I think it was quite representative.
Except the fact that I'm not
always working from the office.
So we try to follow some strict rules
not to be too often in the office.
So it's yeah, partly from
home, partly from the office.
But then it's very similar,
having a long list of calls
throughout the day till the evening.
When we have no traveling restrictions,
obviously, they can be totally different.
So then it's usually for
me, one, two, three days,
sometimes four days of traveling a week,
yeah, to different clients, usually.
Two or three throughout the weeks.
Having steerco meetings,
pitch meetings with potential
new clients, workshops.
Also, internal meetings with BCG,
INVERTO internal, and so on.
Which could mean like
taking the early flight
in the morning and coming
back with the late flight
in the evening, and moving
out the next day again.
But that's then totally
different week by week.
- Makes sense.
So thanks for being and even
allowing us to accompany you.
I think we will give you alone now.
But fill us in how will
now your day continue?
How long will need to go on,
and what does it really look like?
- Yeah, so my official schedule today
says I'm done at 8:30.
I hope that will be true.
And then I can, yeah, take
another 20 minutes bike ride
to go home, get some fresh air.
And that would be great.
- That will sound like a great evening.
- Mm-hmm.
- Thank you, Lars.
Appreciated, all the best to you.
- Yeah, thank you.
- Now a big thank you to INVERTO
for inviting us into their
office here in Munich
and also sponsoring the video.
So as always, if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
And also subscribe to my
channel to stay up to date
on more content like this.
I also have an Instagram.
The handle is firmlearning.
And I also wanna say a big thank you
to all the members of the channel.
You're really making a difference.
Thank you so much.
And indeed, if you wanna
continue your learning journey
with this channel,
now there will be some videos
that will be appearing next
to me that you can check out.
I release new videos
every single Saturday.
So stay tuned for next week.
Good weekend to all of you.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Bye-bye.